- Hello Believe Nation.
Today we're going to
look at the seven things
you should do before quitting your job.
And as always guys, if you hear a point
that really resonates with you
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
And also writing it down
helps you lock it in
for yourself too.
Enjoy.
(electronic music)
So I've always been an advocate
of you don't need to quit your job
and go into your business full time.
I've always been a fan
of doing it on the side
and then eventually getting to the point
where you can quit your job.
And then go full time on your company.
And here are my seven things
that you should look at before
you take that leap full time.
(hiphop beat)
Number one is think
about taking another job.
This might sound a little counterintuitive
because we're talking
about quitting our job
and going full time.
The reason to have a job is to learn.
The reason to have a job
is to make an income right?
You're paying off your
bills and you're learning.
And so I'll be looking at
my current job right now.
If you're not making enough
from your own business to quit
and you need to have a job
then are you learning
enough in the business
that you're in right now?
Are you learning the skills that
are going to help you
with your own company?
If not, then I'd be looking
at how do I get those
skills somewhere else?
How do I quit my job?
And before going all into my business
I have a bridge step at another company
where I'm going to learn.
When your growing up, you pay
to get a University education.
Here you are getting paid to get educated.
You're getting paid to make mistakes.
You're getting paid to make
contacts in the industry.
And so I'd be looking at a company
that has 10 employees or less
that's in the industry
that you want to be in.
It's a company that you look
up to and want to be like
and aspire to learn from.
And go work for them.
And get as close to the
CEO/founder as possible.
Learn, learn, learn, learn, learn.
Take on as many projects as possible
even though they're outside
what you were specifically hired for
so that when you go off
and start your own company
or when you try to build that thing up
you have all the tools, all the experience
all the contacts necessary to do so.
And so if you're not getting those tools
experience and contacts
from your current job
I'd look for a different job first.
(hiphop beat)
Number two is figure
out your business idea.
So one of the great things about being
in an industry that you love
is you get to see how businesses work
and you get to see where
the opportunities are.
And so some of the great businesses
have been founded by people
who are in an industry.
They had a job, they
were talking to customers
and the customers that you were talking to
their needs couldn't be
solved by the current company.
And whenever you hear frustration
from your customer base
and the company you're working at
can't handle that situation
that's an opportunity.
You want to always be thinking to yourself
"Is there something for me here?
"Can I help this customer out?
"Can I help them on the side?
"Can I turn this into my
own business somehow?"
When you're working in the industry
you want to pay attention
to where the holes are.
Where the market opportunities are.
Where the paying points are.
And figure out what
your idea is going to be
for a unique offering to the market.
(hiphop beat)
The number three thing to
do is figure out a plan.
You need to have a plan.
You need to think about
once you have your idea
now how will you build
a business around it?
How are you going to get new customers?
How are you going to market yourself?
How are you going to service the
customers that you're getting?
How are you going to get
word-of-mouth marketing happening?
What's your social media plan going to be?
You start to have a plan.
Now I understand the thing about planning.
The plan is never going to be perfect.
A lot of times people spend
too much time on the plan.
They plan, they plan, they plan, they plan
and they never do.
That's not the solution either.
But you don't want to just jump all in
and not have a plan.
Planning, even though as soon as you start
actually being in business
your plan will change.
It doesn't mean that the
planning process isn't valuable.
So you want to have a plan,
you want to do your research
you want to get everything together
and give yourself some confidence
that this thing is going to work
before just jumping all in on it.
Basically you want to get to the point
where if somebody
presented this thing to you
you would want to invest in it.
So this looks like a good plan.
This looks like a good idea.
Has that level of research
and detail gone into your plan
to help you get to the point
where you could comfortably
show it to somebody else
and say, "That's a really good idea."
(hiphop beat)
For the number four tip
I'm going to turn it
over to my friend Matthew
from the Youtube channel, Trident Lion.
- [Matthew] What's up Believe Nation?
I'm Matthew, a.k.a Trident Lion
from the Trident Lion channel.
And tip number four is
quit your job with low or no risk.
Not all entrepreneurs have the luxury
and capability to take
and tolerate massive risk.
Many of us, including myself
have children we need to provide for.
Hypothetically, it's better to jump ship
by building a better ship while
you're on your current ship.
Rather than jumping ship
and trying to build a ship
while you're swimming.
Imagine being able to leave your job
quit with confidence and certainty.
Quit with your next source of income
being your entrepreneurial dream.
The way to do this is to work.
If you want it bad enough
you have to put in the work after hours.
I came across the
question a few years ago.
The question of, "How do
you build a personal brand
"And/or business while supporting a family
"And working full time?"
And one of the best answers I found
is the advice of one of my
and Evans virtual mentors.
Gary Vaynerchuck.
So for all of you entrepreneurs out there
that cannot tolerate risk
but still want to build
your entrepreneurial dream
here is one powerful and effective way
how to do exactly that.
- So if you have a feel,
if you want to do it
I don't want to hear about
this 9-5 bull (beep).
What's that?
- [Audience Member] I quit!
- You quit?
(laughs)
I quit, nice.
I don't want to hear about
this two job thing right?
9-5, I don't have time.
If you want this, if you're miserable
or if you don't like it
or you want to do something else
and you have a passion somewhere else
work 9-5, spend a couple
hours with your family.
Seven to two in the
morning is plenty of time
to do damage.
(audience laughs)
But that's it.
It's not going to happen any other way.
How do you get money to do what you love?
You don't right?
I lost a (beep) load of money
when I started doing what I loved.
What you do is you position
yourself to succeed.
So for example, if you're
doing something else
and you want to do this thing you love
you do it after hours.
You work 9-6, you get home.
You kiss the dog, and you go to town.
(audience laughs)
Right?
I mean, you start building
your equity and your brand
and whatever you're trying
to accomplish, after hours.
Everybody has time, stop
watching (beep) Lost.
(audience laughs)
- [Matthew] By putting in the work
and being patient
it is possible to turn
your entrepreneurial dream
into your career with practically no risk.
Quitting your job with certainty.
If you want to quit your
job without the risk
putting in the work towards
your entrepreneurial dream
and being patient
those are two important
things that you need to do
before you quit.
Realize if you have a busy schedule
some of us, like I said have
a full time job and children.
So dedicating time for
your entrepreneurial dream
can be limited.
Time efficiency and time effectiveness
should be taken serious.
You don't want to waste your limited time
building an entrepreneurial dream
on unimportant tasks.
One great solution to this
is to utilize Pareto's Law.
Consider and ask yourself
what is the most important 20% of the work
that goes into building
my entrepreneurial dream
for 80% of the outcome?
If you want to quit your job
to have a career doing
your entrepreneurial dream
with little to no risk
like Gary Vee has said, do it after hours.
Put in the work, be
patient, be persistent.
Learn as you go.
Grow as you learn
and be sure to never
quit on creating a life
doing your personal entrepreneurial dream.
So there you have the
number four thing to do
before quitting your job.
(hiphop beat)
- My number five tip is run the numbers.
So I think you should start at a company
and then do your business on the side.
And the point where you leave your job
to go into your business full time
is when you can make
enough from your business
to pay off all your bills.
So you need to know how much it costs you
to live your life every month.
And it doesn't have to
be a life of luxury.
We're not talking about going out
and buying expensive cars
and going off on expensive trips.
Just the basics, food,
internet, mortgage or rent.
What does that equal every month
so you know here's what I have to make
from my business to survive.
And if you can get to that point
as a part time entrepreneur
then you know, listen I could quit my job
I could spend full time
now working on my business
and I have enough to cover my basics.
Now that I'm spending
more time on my business
I can rapidly grow it up
and earn more as well
but you can't do that
until you know the numbers.
So learn the numbers to know how much
you need to survive
and how much you're
making from your business.
(hip-hop beat)
So number six is then start on the side.
We want to get started.
Don't just have this idea
and do nothing about it.
It's not just have a job
but learn about the industry
and then wait for some
magical moment to start.
No like, start now.
Start on the side, start immediately.
Weekends, evenings, we're going right away
to try to build our business up.
Even if it's free work at the start.
Even if it's spec work
just to build up your portfolio
just to build up your experience
just to build up the connections
and understanding how the industry works.
It's worth it on the side
to start building some momentum
because it's going to take a while
to get your company off the ground.
It's not just going to happen for you.
And so, starting now
starting and sucking right?
Starting and improving,
slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly.
Take everything that you
learned from your company
that you have your job at
and you're putting it
into your own business.
Building that up.
And not waiting, because too many people
have these great ideas
while they're at a job
and maybe the job sucks
or maybe the job is great
but you still just sit on the idea.
You don't do anything with it.
Well the key is to do something with it
and the hardest part is,
you have this big vision
for where you want to go
and you know you can't do it right now.
And a lot of people
just sit on the vision.
They just sit on the idea.
Well you stick to the big vision
this is the big thing that we want to do
that I want to build
but I'm starting here.
I'm going to take a step and another step
and another step and another step.
It's thinking big and acting small.
Most people think big
and act zero, do nothing.
So find a way to start today, immediately.
Every single day you're
spending time on your business
to move your idea forward.
(hiphop beat)
And then number seven is
hit your survival number.
This is last step.
Once you hit that survival number
and you know here's what I need to live
and I've hit it
it's having the courage
to say, "I'm ready to go."
You know, maybe taking a pay-cut
I'm not making as much as I am
now with my combined salaries
from my businesses and the job I have
but this business is the thing
that you wanted to build.
You've hit your survival number.
It's having the courage to leave that job
take all the time you spent there
and pour it into your company
and really build something
you can be proud of.
So once you've hit that survival number
you got to have the
courage to act, to do it.
To take the leap, to jump.
And to have the confidence that your thing
is going to work out.
So that's my take on the seven things
that you need to do
before quitting your job.
I'd love to know, what did you guys think?
Which rule was your favorite?
Do you have an eight,
nine, ten that you'd like
to add to the list?
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also wanted to thank
Matthew from Trident Lion
for his point number four
as well Matthew picked
up a copy of my book
Your One Word, and made
an awesome book review
on his channel as well.
So thank you Matthew for the love.
I really, really appreciate it
and I'm glad that you
enjoyed the book as well.
- [Matthew] Now I would like
to express some gratitude
to Evan Carmichael.
Thank you for having me on this video
and being featured on your channel.
Also, thank you for your
book, Your One Word.
Creating the summary and
review on it was so fun to do.
And it certainly has helped
myself and my brand level up.
- So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.